they said i should be denounced and i
should never be hired again
so that was pretty tricky so i then
hired a lawyer
straight away and i said you've got to
withdraw that statement and all that
sort of stuff and pay my costs which
they did that was good
but still the thing about these great
attacks that people
launch on you is once they've launched
the attack on you it sticks
as long as they throw enough [ __ ] some
of it will stick so they
you know you sort of walk around but
weirdly when i walk around the
streets people come up to me and go
thank god for you but when i walk around
on twitter people come up to me and go
i hope you and your family die soon yeah
standard game
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
british actor
and activist he's also the founder of
the reclaim party and hopefully
the next mayor of london lawrence fox
welcome to the reuben report
hi dave how you doing i'm doing just
fine sir i am glad to talk to you
across the pond uh for my american
audience that maybe
doesn't know who you are can you give me
the quick
recap of lawrence fox before we talk
about all the reasons
that you got yourself into trouble and
how you got into politics and all that
well i was an actor and um actually some
of your american
friends will know me because i got off
the plane at jfk once and
and a guy was helping me in my bags he
said i love you in the
inspector louis show so um that was
quite sweet i was active for many years
and then yeah like you say
i got into trouble i got cancelled all
right so let's talk
about your cancellation you were on uh
a british show called question time it's
about about a year ago now
and we're going to play a clip in just a
second but can you just sort of set up
what question time is and how you even
got involved in it as an actor
and uh a little bit of the behind the
scenes portion
sure yeah um so question time is a sort
of topical panel show
uh political panel show in the uk it's
been around for donkeys years
and um it's usually quite very
left-leaning you know and sort of very
establishment
but by some accident they invited a
slightly
more centrist panel on and i was
promoting because i'm a musician as well
so i was promoting an album and someone
said to me do you want to go on question
time and i'm like yeah sure you know
because
it's a sort of family tradition in the
uk people just shout at the tv and go
it's rubbish
no you're wrong and i thought i'd get to
do that on
live tv um and then yeah this
uh a woman started asking questions of
of me it's saying asking what my opinion
was about something and i
said what my opinion was she disagreed
and said i wasn't allowed an opinion
because i was white
so i was like oh hang on that's racist
so i said don't be racist
and then uh boom so let's
we're gonna just throw to that one 30
second clip right now
let's be really clear about what this is
let's call it by its name
it's racism they're the most tolerant
lovely country
in europe
what worries me about your comment is
you are a white privileged male
who hasn't always
can i can't help what i am i was born
like this it's an immutable
characteristic so to call me a white
privileged male is to be racist
so boy you claimed
that you're entitled to opinion even
though you're white how radical of you
it's awful isn't it i mean we should
have learned by now that you're not
allowed an opinion
immutable characteristics ahead of
everything else but it was weird i i was
not
i didn't know it was such an enormous
landmine in the uk so it was
it was crazy the next day i got a bit of
support and then it just went mad
left uh twitter went went for me yeah so
can you talk about that experience
because you know obviously
we're in the midst of this just insane
cancel culture thing and on any given
day we're taking out pepe le pew or mr
potato head or aunt jemima
or so or sometimes real people too um
but can you just talk about what it
feels like
to be the target of that because that's
when you came on my radar suddenly i was
you know it was basically like oh here's
a guy telling the truth
and then just to watch the mob
send on you it was it was
i was okay until the actors union the
equity the actors union you know you
know how um non-left-wing
show business oh yes yes yeah they're
very fair
they went they asked they asked they
said i should be denounced
and i should never be hired again so
that was pretty tricky
so i then hired a lawyer straight away
and i said you've got to withdraw that
statement and all that sort of stuff and
pay my costs which they did that was
good
but still the thing about these great
attacks that people
launch on you is once they've launched
the attack on you it sticks
as long as they throw enough [ __ ] some
of it will stick so they
you know you sort of walk around but
weirdly when i walk around the
streets people come up to me and go
thank god for you but when i walk around
on twitter people come up to me and go
i hope you and your family die soon yeah
standard game right so what would you
say to the people who would say oh but
this is just
some online thing then it's just the
twitter mob and you should get over just
people being mean on twitter you don't
have to be on twitter
well it twitter is pointless and a sewer
of humanity which is fine but um
it's but also it does affect people in
real life like the mayor of london the
sitting mayor of london at the moment
sadiq khan he's like
he takes sort of virtue signing our
identitarianism to a whole new level
of division he called me in the
newspaper when they were asked for a
comment about me he called me a far
right extreme far right guy and i'm like
okay that's pretty uncool because i've
got two kids
i can walk to around the shop if someone
who's only ever read that little bit of
newspaper which is the
capital city newspaper and someone
decides they want to put a brick or a
knife into me
then this whole sort of freedom of
speech thing because i'd actually defend
his right to call me an extreme far
right whatever he wants to call me
he's a bit of a wanker to be fair i
don't care but um we'll get to him in
just a moment
you know when they say that they go
freedom of speech and then freedom of
consequences of the freedom of speech
i'm like if my kids get attacked or if i
get attacked who's the consequences on
are they on you and also can you say one
simple thing that i've ever said which
is even vaguely by the way
right so okay so basically the usual
story unfolds you say a very moderate
thing in line with british values
defending free speech which is really
what you were doing on the
on the panel the whole time uh next
thing you know the mayor is calling you
far right there's a gajillion hit pieces
you've got the union going after you the
twitter mob like
all of that stuff and then you
sort of i think once you got over it you
kind of embraced it because your life in
the last year i mean you started a
political party you're running for mayor
you you kind of ran right into the fire
you can't do anything else there's no
there's no option
there's no i'm i'm good friends with
winston marshall as well and you know
i've been watching from mumfords and
watching while he's trying to put out
there he's trying to bow to the woke mob
and you know and he's
he's actually trying to do the right
thing really but i'm just sat there
going
don't do it buddy yeah don't do it to be
clear he's the
he's the guitarist guitarist right for
mumford inside
player banjo player from bumper designs
he's the one who dared
to recommend andy knows scary book about
antifa i mates with both of them
and i'm on the phone to both of them and
andy's andy's in the uk at the moment
because i want andy's come and work for
for me for the party i really would like
that so um i'm mates with both them it's
hilarious
and they love each other and then
there's this sort of public
crap storm going on around well you know
different approaches to deal with a woke
mob who you can never say sorry to
yeah they love it has he heard any of
your feelings about this like
that you just can't apologize that this
is gonna get you nowhere i mean he's not
even in the band anymore right at least
temporarily
i was speaking we were laughing about it
on on the phone you know it's really
difficult it's like how do you if you're
a
he's a truly compassionate gentle guy he
doesn't want
major conflicts in life i know i don't
mind being punched in the face
for stuff i believe in but i think he's
just trying to do the right thing
and actually i you know i think you can
people that do give in they need more
love because
you know it's it's just people hanging
around the guillotine right going
more more beheadings you know that's
what they're like it's
it's gives me the shivers i like
standing up to them
they need it well and they they do need
it so all right so
assuming that you're not far right i'm
willing to
go on this adventure with you okay
because
in your twitter bio you describe
yourself as a fierce
liberal what does liberal
mean to you at this point because i know
there's a slightly different
british version you know my feelings on
classical liberalism
do you think the word liberal can be
saved does it even make sense
in in the sort of modern context anymore
i think yeah you do have a site uh
difficulty with it in america don't you
because i've got some
american friend bought me a mug saying
liberal tea is still warm but so
but that's leftists to us here right um
i am my liberalism is would now
probably with the overton window where
it is in
society would probably be seen as quite
right-wing you know i want people to get
on with their own lives make their own
decisions about what they do
and keep as much of their money as
possible then not pay it to an enormous
state so
you know it's just about being free to
make your own decisions in life that's
where my liberalism comes from
um and yeah i think we can save it
because ultimately it's going to be
weirdly it's going to be the left of
center liberals that
that save the situation because until
they start standing up
there's no point in people like me going
guys there's a big problem here with
freedom of speech we're going to have a
big fight if we're not careful
we need people from the left to come in
and go this isn't cool
and it's starting to happen they're
eating their own as well yeah what what
signs
are you seeing like i i've just sort of
come around to to that
the the same liberals just need
they don't have to change their beliefs
at all i mean i wrote a whole book
defending liberalism but they have to
ally
with the moderates on the right which i
think is most of america at this point
just freedom loving people and we can
debate about tax rates and all that kind
of stuff do you see
some signs that the the decent liberals
are waking up and fighting some of the
woke stuff because there's not much here
there's just not much it's a it's it's a
very um
it's a very difficult subject for
politicians certainly to get involved
we've got a conservative party here
which is i mean
they're not even vaguely conservative
they're almost the socialist party on
their own
and then the opposition party is even
more left-wing than that
so we're in we're in difficult difficult
times
actually because it's an attack on
everything isn't it it's not
a con um you know it's an attack on
values
uh love of family love of country it's
it's an attack on all the things that
are
were okay to be you know to to love and
and we had this horrible murder a few
days ago in london of this
uh girl and then there was a vigil held
for her and the police
got um too too involved really because
they
they've turned we've basically turned
into a police state here and within
minutes it turned into a leftist
demonstration so we're now getting
we're getting what you have in portland
starting
to the rumblings of in london screaming
neurotic lunatics going on like that one
minute they'll go who streets our
streets and then they'll be on to
[ __ ] the police kill the police they
just they don't know what they're
screaming about but they're angry
yeah are they organized in any way i
mean this is the big debate in america
is antifa just an idea
like is andy tracking this andy no is is
that why he's there right now
yeah andy was there the other day yeah
he's checking it
um i don't think they're that organized
i think social media is helpful isn't it
for crazy people with crazy views to get
together
so what are they even protest i mean
from a british perspective what are they
protesting
or they just don't i i i went to the
protest
so i was like i need to know what these
guys are upset about
and i couldn't work it out they were
just screaming it was one thing to the
next you know
it was meant to be about this this
dreadful crime this murder of this woman
but it became about something else it
was like let's kill the police and it
was acab
all cops are bastards and it's like well
are they
you know i don't understand no one knew
what was going on they were just
marching up and down the street and then
they went and lay down in trafalgar
square for a while
i think basically none of either they
weren't paying attention at school
or they're not interested in history
yeah
how do you think the lockdowns fit into
this because
you guys are still in pretty severe
lockdowns right now
we are in severe lockdown no one's
paying any attention to it though it's
so british
it's like yes we might they whenever
they poll the british people they're
like are you all in lockdown are you
supportive of it and the brit's like yes
absolutely we're supportive and then i
walk out my door and
down the street and i look at on the
window it says stay at home protect the
nhs save lives and then you look
downstairs and people having a drinks
party
so it's um it's it's do as i uh say not
do as i do
yeah so all right you're a radical
right-wing
guy trying to defend the extreme
right-wing extreme
right-winger trying to defend liberalism
so you walk in through the fire
you decide okay i'm not going to be
canceled i'm going to see what happens
and then how did you make the shift to
say well i'm actually going to freaking
start a political party and run for
office
it's one thing to survive it but then to
really say i'm going in and i'm going to
do something
well it's just such a gap so like we did
um i mean after this we did i had a
feeling that there was a large
constituency of people that just weren't
being allowed to express themselves
so um there's just this huge freedom of
speech hole
so i thought that needs mending because
we have to have a proper debate about
everything
including lockdowns actually weirdly
because they have they haven't been
talked about they've just been
you must accept that lockdowns are a
good thing and there's no debate allowed
so yeah i got approached by a very rich
businessman who said do you what do you
want to do because you will not lie down
you're like
you keep standing up like some like some
stupid boxer who doesn't know when the
battle is finished
and i said well i should do some
immediate and i actually mentioned you
because you're actually responsible for
some of this as i told you before and
again i apologize
you know and
he said no no you need a political party
he said they'll only ever listen to you
if you have a political party
so weirdly we we started up the
political party and um
things suddenly the culture became
important again to our conservative
government because they're trying to
hold me off
on their on what is what it would
essentially be the liberal side of
things but it's now the sort of extreme
far right as on lovely miracles
yeah so this morning i i read the i went
to the reclaim website and you
you basically write an open letter
describing why you started the party and
and what the beliefs are and uh i
thought it was quite
perfect actually um can you can you
describe some of the principles
these again these crazy right-wing
liberal principles that you
that you're defending well i think it's
it's really simple i'm defending an idea
so it's not really about me
anyway so that you know you should be
you should be able to protect yourself
from an attack if you believe in freedom
of speech you believe in
everybody's freedom to speak right and
um
so that's what i stand for i stand for
the the biggest and broadest
debates to be had possible and um then
what i've done sort of practically
is i've commissioned which is actually
going to be quite big news in england
soon which is going to shock them i've
commissioned a
full and huge legal review of our
of all of the legal impingements on
freedom of speech because you know
you've got your equality act going
through and what's it called hr one or
whatever's going through in america
now we had this [ __ ] they did this in
like 2010 in the uk we have our own
equality act where people are
have protected characteristics and
they're not they're not equal under the
law
so we all of this stuff is really
dangerous legislation
and um i commissioned a full review in
this very eminent
top top top people who have put together
a suggestion for the british people and
for the parliament
about how we can lose division in
society
but it's weird when you try and lose
division you tend to attract divisive
people
yeah it seems to be are are are you
worried that in essence
you'll sort of like just at a
like practical level that you'll sort of
split the conservatives because some
conservatives will go with you the rest
will stay with the conservatives and
then ultimately you just help labor and
the labor party
has as you sort of said before kind of
gone off the rails
i think the conservative candidate in
london is not he's a he's such a sweet
guy as well which i find
so difficult because he's a really
lovely guy but he's not for some reason
he's not
creating the right waves so um
no i think what i want and what would be
best would be
for me and siddique our mayor
who likes to race bait on a daily basis
um to debate and talk about our capital
city and you know what's his vision for
it and
because you know he's he's got this is
called the commission for diversity in
the public realm
he's got and it sounds lovely so it
always sounds lovely
it always sounds lovely but it's just
like let's tear down all our statues
and um he's already had to kick one
member off he's in a vowed
surprisingly for the left extreme left
an avowed anti-semite who would have
thought it shocking in the labor party i
can't believe it
are you it's weird isn't it right the
people that call you racist they are the
exact thing they accuse you of
so um he's uh i've lost my
my train now so in essence though you
you want it you want to debate sadiq
khan and yeah and
do you sense that that could happen or
or is it a pipe dream i mean
will he do it who knows man
we've got um we've got a pretty cool
campaign
on thursday we're going to start um
dropping the
you know some of the more importantly
controversial but
needing to be said statements to london
i mean look at the end of the day london
is like the cathedral of woke
like any metropolitan center so i
for me the most important thing is just
to
raise the voice for the people who don't
get to speak that's it it's the only
reason i do it
so all right so you guys are seeing some
violence in london uh
with sort of sort of newish violence
there's the lockdowns
we were mentioning right before we
started recording you know we have a
couple friends in common douglas murray
and
and peter lloyd and a few other people
peter basically has fled
london and everyone that i talk to
that's in london is really not happy
about what's going on there what
what besides the free speech stuff has
sadiq khan
done wrong well he's um he's a he's
what has he done right really is the way
he starts all right
he's terrible we've got a surging knife
crime
problem in london and then that's made
almost unsolvable because of
the way that he stokes racial tensions
between people so
you know he calls you a racist if you
try and deal with knife crime he would
call you a racist
he's um he's obviously trying to tear
down all of our
um of our shared history and um you know
he what did he say the other day he said
something like there's just no reason
why
there should be 65 of these people
should be white men working in this
particular field and you're like
hang on a minute dude just slow down
this country is 83 or 85 white
of course it's going to be more white
people you know he's
it's this very specific demonization of
white people
and fortunately he has a huge
constituency of white people who also
hate themselves as well you know the
sort of white
urban liberals and it's it's like
it's really sad because most of the
working class in the united kingdom
would usually vote labor
you know they would but labor don't
represent labor
they don't represent laborers and they
don't represent actually the important
things which are class
issues in this country you know britain
is constantly infrequent i think
after new zealand and i can't remember
where else we are the most tolerant
country on earth you know in terms of
like tolerance of intermarriage and all
this sort of stuff so i don't know why
at the center of the altar of woke our
mayor is trying to turn around and go
you know what guys you're all racists
it's like come on man it's 2021. we've
got to get a new story
yeah well it's basically it's all they
got right i mean that that's in essence
what you were saying in that
clip earlier like it's it's all they got
without that what what policy could he
possibly be pushing that makes any sense
i know he doesn't have any policies so
he's and also the worst part of it is
he's
he's kind of a government stooge as well
so the government
the government are bribing him to make
him look bad and it's
it's just so political and i i can't
bear it so when i get into
involved in this stuff i just go listen
i don't have any lobbies or vested
interests
i'm not i'm not supported or funded by
these people so this is what i would do
to solve
x y and z problem so we'll just have to
see does it feel
to you guys like a lot of this stuff has
been imported from the us
that our bad ideas or the bad ideas that
have taken
root here suddenly are exported all over
the place
yeah i mean when you go to what the bbc
described as a
largely peaceful protest of the black
lives matter last summer there were
people walking around going hands up
don't shoot and i'm like
our police force isn't they literally
don't have guns
we've imported this straight from
america which is a great honor to
america
because you know we love american trends
and all that stuff but this is one
american trend i wish it stayed behind
but at least you get to keep megan right
well apparently she's gonna run for
president now that's that's the new meme
we're hearing and she'd win
oh she'd win wouldn't she where are we
gonna where are we gonna go
fiji fiji that's the spot yeah
that's yeah that's the spot so all right
so america's
importing this or exporting this stuff
you guys are are importing this stuff
um what's it gonna take is it is it okay
we can
take back london by by getting the sane
mayor like what what's the real move
to really reverse this thing well
there's an interesting thing that's
developed now so
a um there's a there's a constituency on
the
in the north of britain called the red
wall which was always held by the labour
party and it
totally fell down the friction and went
to the conservatives they lent
their votes to the conservatives some
constituencies haven't hadn't voted
conservative for a hundred years
and um today um one of the
labor weirdly why would it be the labor
guy who's been done for sexual
harassment and have to resign
in immediately it's weird that that's
always them too isn't it it's so bizarre
what's going on here it's almost like
they're the exact thing they accuse us
of
um so that he's had to stand down today
so there's now going to be a by-election
and it'll be very very interesting to
see what happens up there but ultimately
i think
if you can open up the dialogue and you
can say listen there's 70 million people
in this country
we're not all racists we're not and i
will stand up and say we're not
then you you it's you know these guys
have been doing this for decades haven't
they marching through our universities
not even my
my kids right my youngest son said to me
i'm sorry this is racist dad but mum is
a better cook than you
and i'm like what say what now
so they're man they're filling it in
their heads
like constantly when trump got ill um
well he didn't really get ill did he
really get covered but when
whatever two days he disappeared they
announced it in the school assembly
you know and then everyone started
cheering and it's like my little son was
like i didn't want to cheer i don't want
to cheer when someone's not very well
so they they're hammering it in the
educational establishment is really bad
i think what you have to do is they
march through the institution slowly
we'll march straight back in so do you
think the institutions are
are worth saving or would you say that
they should be just
rebuilt or or just totally new
institutions
i i think they have to be reclaimed that
i think that's why i call it reclaim
yeah and they have to be reclaimed it's
95 percent of academics are pretty hard
left
um in university and that's not cool you
can't have a good debate when
95 people agree with each other and
they've bought into even
old acting school has bought totally
brought into critical race theory and
anti-racism and stuff like that
but i thought it was excellent what
prince william said when he said
this family is not racist and that was a
deliberate little spike at his brother
and his sort of weird anti-racist
narcissist
crap from his puppet master wife you
know
what what's going on with that whole
situation you know i
covered it for like two seconds on the
show i didn't watch the full open
interview it's not that
interesting to me honestly from an
american perspective we just have bigger
problems
at the moment um but but is megan gonna
like
take down the whole monarchy that's kind
of what it feels like like that she's
gonna import
all of these horrible ideas and just
that this is a threat to everything i
don't think she will succeed
because i think there's a huge amount of
goodwill there like if you look at the
photos of that wedding particularly
where they're
you know there's so much goodwill i mean
you know we have princes and princesses
in this country right you're not gonna
hate your prince and princess
so there was so much good will but what
we cannot abide
is what she's done which she's trying to
to make her
she's a being political which you know
you shouldn't be doing as a royal
i think she's just taken control of a
very compassionate guy
and she's she's realized she's not going
to be the center of attention
so she's gone right well i don't want to
be in the royal family anymore and then
you know in true kind of vengeful
narcissist style she's gone um right i'm
gonna take him down so she's accused all
of them of being racist by not being
particular about what it is
and it's a very it's a very you know and
i know how powerful that insult is
because i
get called racist all the time and it
really affects you
you know especially if you've got a
heart you're like ow i was not expecting
to be called that
and so i think what will happen is the
royal family will just find a very cool
very calm way of going i know
stay over there how does the
media play into all of this because you
guys
are well known for your tabloid media
i've had the guardian call me racist and
far right and all of that
stuff so even though we've obviously
exported a lot of the bad ideas one of
the things that i think that you guys
have exported is some of like the
tabloid journalism kind of stuff like
it's now
everywhere here it's like basically
there's no difference between
the the national enquirer and the new
york times at this point
yeah former newspaper um it's it's very
it's it's very sad it's been
particularly sad over lockdown
because the government briefed the and
they're now finding redacted statements
within the
scientific advisory group that have been
saying we need to get the people
frightened and stuff like this
so the government have briefed the media
and the media have loved it they've then
set the whole population on fire and
fear and now
everyone is terrified and they can't
move so i think the media
are you know but it's free speech right
i'm like say what you want
man but just can we just have
more of the whole picture instead of
just this very
focused picture on on what we want to
what we want to attack and what is
you know relevant to to to your kind of
selling newspaper's narrative
it's been bad but even piers morgan got
even by the crocodile yeah
how's piers doing right now after he
walked off the set
he was i was quite friendly with piers
and then um
we fell out over kovid um so i've
i've been saying to that he's um now
that he's
realized because he jumps on bandwagons
as you know in america you know when
shapiro when shapiro just ate him for
breakfast
over there assault rifle stuff so he's
doing the same thing he's just
reinventing himself we've got a new news
channel
opening up in the uk called gb news
which is run by andrew neal who's
probably one of the best journalists
we have in the country and hopefully
that will bring a bit more balance into
it but they're already trying to get
that cancelled as well
yeah do you guys have like uh like who
are the british
voices that we should know that that we
don't know
like who el who else is putting you on
on the map right now
definitely andrew neal um the the
newspapers that have not given in
to the woke agenda but some of them have
uh most of them have but the telegraph
newspaper hasn't really given in
the the times did this horrible
evisceration of jordan peterson
the other day and i was just like [ __ ]
you yeah you know
[ __ ] you i was saying that was meant to
be a sort of centrist
moderate paper and they're just like
stab stab stab so
the telegraph the express which you know
if you'd said the express 10 years ago
or 15 years ago in the uk they would
have gone nazi
but now it's like a bastion of centrism
it's weird
it's weird what about because i know i
know what people will say
okay you guys are saying you're down
playing racism
and what what about the real
uh people that actually are racist the
the real
far right people whatever whatever
influence those
groups have first off do they have any
real influence at this point because in
american context
there are no legit political
racist groups there just aren't that
isn't to say there aren't
racist people there are of course but
they have been marginalized
are you trying to say that the left
create imaginary bogeymen
i'm starting to think we think in a
similar way
um the yeah so the far right in england
um it does exist but i mean there's
probably a
there's not very many of them you know
it's not and they don't really have any
power no one listens to them you know
also having the best time ever because
seeing as everyone's a racist they're
just hiding in plain sight right
no i think i think the thing is
we we in this sort of new woke religion
that we've
found ourselves in and we're looking for
heaven heaven is
is a world of no racism which everyone
would like a worldwide racism but
unfortunately
human beings are fallen and not they
have to kill an awful lot of
indulgation yeah you're going to find
that there are going to be some actual
racists and what you want to do is
educate their children
that's all you want to do you know
you've got a nasty racist dude what are
you going to try and convince him of
but his kid you can educate and
hopefully
his child can turn out not to be racist
you know but we've done
i'm so i mean i'm brazenly patriotic
about
this country i think we're amazing and i
think you know america has kind of
fallen
for the next four years we'll see what
happens china is powerful actually
you've got
really i love the fact that you get your
own um
soldiers get there get to choose the
color of their own combat gear now that
sounds
yes yes china's sticking their traps at
the moment
china's just going this is great um and
we've got
so i think england needs we need to look
at england and go what do you guys think
and i think you need to go well we
believe that we must stand freely
together i mean and we see all men and
women
unequal under the law i mean what's so
complicated about that crap that's a 75
issue in our country it's it's almost
like you should do the things that
you've been doing for a long time
something like that see see
if that's thousand years see if that
sort of
900 years since the magna carta was
worth carrying on
pursuing or hang on a minute no let's
just tear the whole thing down and start
again
what do you want to start with leftists
nothing just fire and chaos
i'm like nothing quotas don't fire chaos
in quotas don't forget the quotas
the exactly must remember the questions
where does where does brexit
fit into all of this and do you feel
freer
now than you did say well i guess not
because of lockdowns but
putting lockdowns aside would you feel a
little freer now
i think brexit is amazing i didn't vote
for brexit i voted to remain because i
just like why change it you know instead
of my vibe
but now that i've seen how duplicitous
and
evil the european union have been
certainly over the vaccine stuff and
over northern ireland
brexiteers are now probably just below
deploral just above deplorable status
so you wouldn't spit at them in the
streets but you would try and have them
cancelled from
from work um yeah brexit was a very big
central cultural issue for our country
so um you know there's still people who
maraude around online actually most of
the bullies have a european flag in
there
um in their twitter bio and it says fbpe
follow back pro europe
and um i think brexit has has
divided the country but i imagine that
52 that voted brexit are probably
now if you want if you did that vote
again i think you find it probably
more 60 40. so you think people people
realize
that being in charge of their own lives
is better than outsourcing it to
brussels
crazy outsourcing it to an unelected
body
yeah exactly yeah i think it's um i
think it's been really good
i'm really i think it's like exciting
but the problem is boris johnson's had
this chance to go
right we've done brexit what are we
going to look like what are we going to
what are we going to be
as a country and instead he's gone like
okay darling more with prompt
more insurance what's the deal with
boris i think a lot of people thought he
was going to be
much more bullish and bold than he's
been and it sounds like that just kind
of hasn't happened
mistress not now yeah he's his girl
yeah yeah his girl his his girlfriend is
um she's a she's an entirely new level
of woke
god and he's got a load of kids
apparently who are also woke
because boris is boris was never good at
knowing how many children he had exactly
so um he's um he does a good line in it
right but he's the thing is
he's he's a trained classicist so if
you've got a national health service
here going
we're gonna rename breastfeeding chest
feeding you're like
come on dude you're a classical linguist
you you should care about language but
he's just like
so he's all about dolphins and wind
turbines
which is great for when it's friendly
i can't tell are you are you hopeful or
pessimistic
generally speaking i just i'm not
i'm i'm sort of i'm optimistic but i
find this
whole thing so amusing it's so difficult
not to find it
mad do you know what i mean you're
sitting there going are we
sitting through a very important period
of history we are
i never thought i'd watch it my dad is
81 and he said to me the other day i was
like how do you feel he went
i'm just glad i'd be dead soon i'm so
glad i
won't be around when the fire starts i'm
like oh dad
but he does know you're trying to put
out the fire so
yeah and he's cool my dad like he's he's
there
he's a good inspiration for me so we
walk a lot uh you know and we talk and
he he's smart about these things
so we can we can put the fire out i
think ultimately what will happen is
people would just go
stop and i think my mates who've got
kids who are like 16
15 16 they're not working at all
they hate them that that seems to be the
new thing that that the zoomers
like that generation the the upper teens
right now that they're going to reject
this stuff
with a boldness that somehow well
certainly the
the baby boomers failed on and you know
we're roughly the same age that our our
gen z people failed on but but that they
won't hopefully
yeah i think i think they are they are
the hope otherwise it's going to be
chaos isn't it it's going to be like the
it's almost like the french revolution
but the wind up the thing that i find so
terrifying about it is you're constantly
goading because obviously we
get america about two months later so
you've now gone from white privilege to
white supremacy
and we're now getting the white
supremacy thing and you're saying this
to like
one of the poorest constituencies in the
country so
white working-class boys in england
chances of them going to university are
very very low
so you're turning around to a bunch of
poor white kids and saying
check your privilege and then you've
also got a whole load of communities
from asia all the way across from india
to china
who don't get included in black lives
matter so it's like it's so divisive
and it's so unpleasant so i think it
should be stood up against i mean
it's just unfair that i'm kind of blonde
and blue-eyed because
it's just exactly the wrong skin color
makeup
to make the opposing or it's exactly the
right one because
it's just enough of this and that's why
i wanted to have you on the show because
you aren't afraid of this thing like you
had your
your moment and you didn't run a lot of
people they put that apology out there
and you never hear from them again
and you didn't do it uh what else should
we tell people about the reclaimed party
and
and how they can help you and get word
out there and all that good stuff
well um you can you can go we're not
accepting donations at the moment
because i want people to see that
i am working rather than getting
freebies
um so you can just spread the word man
all i've been saying
to when someone says how can i help you
as i say find something you disagree
with and go and have a conversation with
them
that's the best thing you can do to help
the reclaimed party and actually your
own culture and your society
stay stay the right way up lawrence fox
you
are a fierce liberal in the best sense
of
liberal for whatever for whatever sense
that word still has you are you are
the best type so thanks for doing this
we're going to link obviously to the to
the party down below and
uh good luck and can i host the debate
between you and sadiq you think uh you
think he'd come on the show
what do you think what do you think you
you should invite him on the show
because i think that he's
so keen on being right on and you know
you're super
you know would he know it'd be i'd be
really interested in seeing he doesn't
really do interviews
like even the other day when someone was
trying to ask him because he's closed
off all the neighborhoods in london as
well right so he's gone
if it's not an essential journey you
won't make it because i will just close
off all the neighborhoods so these
people are trying to talk to him about
it go but why do you get shoes if it's
an essential journey
and he just he has like six he's like a
mafia boss got six security guards fleet
of range rovers
all on the taxpayer dollar he's he's
quite a character man i would like to
yeah you got your work cut out for you
well i do hope it happens we're going to
link to
reclaimed party down below lawrence good
luck man
peace brother if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell